spider-man no way home might have just
served up one of the most emotionally
devastating endings in the marvel
cinematic universe to date and this is
coming from the franchise that gave us
this i don't know what's happening
i don't want to go i don't want to go
please oh you don't want to go
no way home concludes with the
multiverse breaking apart forcing dr
strange to do everything in his power to
stop it from crumbling after cosmic
cracks form in the sky silhouettes of
various characters appear each ready to
enter the mcu dimension it's at this
point that peter parker realizes that
they can prevent the multiverse from
breaking by having strange make the
world forget who peter parker is
including those he loves most
considering the hefty emotional weight
to this whole scene you might be
forgiven for having missed some of the
characters who appeared within those
inter-dimensional doorways they're kind
of hard to make out and they don't
appear for long but if you look closely
enough you may be able to catch a few
surprising cameos right now there's been
no official confirmation about who
exactly appears in the cracks at first
glance they may even appear as
intentionally distorted images designed
to give the impression that they could
be pretty much anyone however for the
keen comic book observer some of those
silhouettes definitely seem more
recognizable than others the figure most
likely to stand out in fans minds is
that of rhino bearing a striking
resemblance to the comic book iteration
of the character as opposed to paul
giamante's more mechanical version from
the amazing spider-man 2. this of course
seems to suggest that the tear in
reality would have brought in many more
variants on spider-man villains than
those fans know from previous movies and
it seems like we might have seen a few
who haven't appeared on screen at all
since seeing no way home mcu fans and
audiences have suggested that some of
the other villains on display in the
final showdown include scorpion and
craven the hunter while those foes
haven't suited up on screen just yet
there have been teases to suggest they
could enter the live-action sphere
craven aka sergey kravenov is one of the
more obvious figures in the way home
thanks to the spear the silhouette
appears to be holding you can also make
out some thickness around the
silhouette's shoulders and head which
could be the mane of the signature
lion's pelt the scorpion figure is a
little more challenging to make out but
it's easier to see once you know it's
there this villain appears to be bent
over with a tail that curves up just
behind him in this appearance it looks
like scorpion is crawling as opposed to
standing up suggesting that this is a
slightly different version from that
which appears in the main comic books
it's probably a good time for marvel to
be referencing these particular villains
craven is getting his own sony produced
movie in the near future while scorpion
was hinted at in spider-man homecoming
in that movie matt gargan appears as a
potential buyer for the vulture's
weapons
he subsequently appears in the
post-credits scene for the movie in
which he attempts to learn spider-man's
real identity through vulture i've got
some boys on the outside who would love
to meet him you know take a picture
slice his throat put his head in the
dryer
seeing how no way home's ending has set
up a whole new era for the mcu
spider-man it's entirely within the
realm of reason that scorpion might
appear as a proper villain in the future
while craven scorpion and rhino have
been the three most discussed villains
from the crackling sky scene a few other
famous comic book characters are thought
to have been spotted too one of them is
black cats whose appearance shouldn't
come as much of a surprise since
spider-man producer amy pascal has
suggested that the infamous thief is
bound for the big screen in the future
there have also been some other obscure
guesses about who is hiding in the sky
with some fans claiming to have seen
madame webb while others believe they
have spotted the multiverse hopping
vampire known as morlin and who knows
who else might yet be found
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]